and talk to guys of mind of extremes and
it's got an incredible grand scale so
it's very difficult to try and capture
it with images
[Music]
being a show Geographic photographer
creates an opportunity for me to
document the world and you don't know
what you're gonna uncover and you are
going into the unknown there's always a
bit of a nervous excitement
and to get to Antarctica we have to get
across one of the most treacherous
crossings on the planet which is a dry
passage
Antarctica is otherworldly big mountain
ranges and endless seas of ice
and it's a challenging place to document
because it feels like you can never
really do it justice
[Music]
I'm trying to showcase these land of
extremes how every single flake of snow
counts - its building that incredible
landscape
[Music]
it's strange to think that something so
light can compact over thousands of
years and trap so much history in the
glacier I like to be as prepared as I
can be but I want to leave myself open
to inspiration from the environment so
having that happen and it's created a
way we can see what's up all the eyes
onto the beach those is kind of
beautiful coincidences that happen and
that's when those really special images
tend to eventuate I find out the colors
in Antarctica pulls you out of yourself
yet it is the most present that we get
to be
[Music]
who can see quite a lot of water pouring
out of the glacier we all know that
Antarctica is deeply impacted by climate
change and I want to try and showcase
that fragility through the macro and the
micro
[Music]
we can hear the eyes releasing the air
bubbles and it sounds like popcorn so we
are recording underwater because most of
the iceberg is under the surface so this
is gonna give us a bit of a glimpse I
was an ultra steady as well it's an
electric feeling to see these images
that I have envisioned and to suddenly
will see them come to life he's
collecting all the little rocks
and he's creating an S
[Music]
what I really love especially with
nature is that it reveals itself gently
in a little bit by bit
I think a big part of my work is
uncovering those moments when I capture
an image that I feel like encapsulate
that moment it's a feeling of coming up
[Music]